do you find it hard to like bring
that energy to your stream even though
like your your schedule is obviously so
busy
there must be some streams where you're
like guys i'm i'm like today i'm just
done honestly like i can't do it today
that's another thing that i have kind of
had to start learning is management of
energy because even if you want to
stream all the time every day you know
to see chat to make them happy et cetera
the end at the end of the day um i only
have so much energy and chat's not gonna
have fun because they can tell when i'm
low energy like i said i've seen
paragraphs analyzing every single facet
of my personality they can tell when
you're low energy that's the truth so
sometimes it's worth it to you know give
yourself a little more breathing room uh
occasionally though i get a little ahead
of myself schedule too many streams uh
it'd be like that and it's taken quite a
toll on my energy in that after i'm done
streaming i just go lay down and that's
the only thing i do besides streaming
and making music is sleeping so it's
something how much sleep do you get for
a day six hours a night which is not
terrible but it's not a little bit yeah
yeah yeah so i'm trying to work on that
a little bit um but there's just a lot
to do and there's a lot you have to put
your energy into and um when it comes to
music one thing that i've noticed is
that it takes a little less energy for
me simply because there's no pressure
about making mistakes on stream you know
in your work process nobody really sees
all the awful mistakes that you make
when you're recording 100 takes over and
over again you put it together and the
song that you've made is hopefully if
you've done it right the best possible
thing that you could have made it be
right with streaming it's just go be
good at improv be good at games be good
at something be perfect for the next two
hours exactly
and just pray um and that takes a lot of
energy out of you you know there's a lot
of stress that comes with that um that
maybe you can be really good at hiding
maybe you're not so good at hiding it um
it just it just depends man and it's
rough it's uh i feel like you've got to
learn it along the way as well because
no one no one's ever prepared to be like
okay i'm going to stream even though
like i'm like low energy and sometimes
you have to like just force it out of
you and it's just it's so difficult
because that's why i don't stream so
often as well because i also have like a
certain amount of energy and if it's
like below that then it's just not going
to be a good stream i think that a lot
of the time though when you feel rough
or you don't feel like you've got the
energy for a stream yeah often when you
actually start and get into it you kind
of get into the rhythm of it and you
kind of get a lot more energy it also
depends on what you're doing there are
some there are some streams that you're
just like i'm having a good time playing
this or i'm having a good time doing
this activity and there's some streams
where you're just like this isn't an
okay time and i have to make it seem
like it's a lot more fun than just an
okay time
i mean i do got to admit i think i
barely scraped by in terms of the
personality you need to stream because
not everyone can stream you have to have
a certain kind of personality i don't
know if you guys know this but i've seen
a couple quote unquote
reliable scientific research papers or
whatever somebody said something on the
internet and i took it as fact but this
is i believe it
that's a big quotation
i can i can understand this being true
so you know i'm not saying this is a
fact but
i don't think the human brain was meant
to deal with
ten thousand or so people watching you
all hundred percent yeah
we we weren't built for it now
technically i'm not a human but listen
i have a human body so we're we're going
throughout the research paper exactly
but we really aren't meant to so you
have to have a certain kind of
personality to not mentally collapse
what is that personality is it just you
have to have a little bit of an ego you
have to have a smidge it just needs to
be a little bit it needs to be enough
you know because
not everyone can do it that's just the
truth you have to have a certain kind of
personality you can't brute force it and
that's fine that is absolutely okay but
it's just kind of how it is you can
build it up yourself but yeah it is a
prerequisite
do you see yourself doing the streaming
for a much longer time or do you think
there's like a certain amount of time
where you're just like yeah i'm probably
going to try something different after a
certain amount of time right like a time
limit on this um it does take more
energy for me than some other folks i
think and with that being said i think
that i'd like to try it out and continue
on for a longer time however the
frequency with which i do it may change
at some point because yeah i mean uh
yeah i'll be thoroughly impressed if you
can keep this up for the next year
have you heard about this thing it's
called a it's called weekends it's uh
it's it's where most people like uh
holidays as
well holiday i've heard of that before
yeah but in a sense these days i kind of
find myself sitting down after a stream
being like all right break time watch
something on netflix and um i think to
myself
i want to do something work related and
that's when you know you've become a
workaholic and you've got the illness so
it's good but i i often found the
struggle where
i would sometimes
invest too heavily in work and then i
would think oh i just haven't hung out
with anyone in a long time
and i feel kind of lonely and but but
then i but then i i've spent too much
time working and i can't hang out with
people because they're hanging out with
people who are more consistent they're
hanging out which is totally fair
what do you mean well because if you're
if you're often not available people
don't invite you to things right so if
you if everyone knows that you're not
going to turn up to stuff most of the
time people stop inviting you
so you kind of have to balance very
carefully and like going to stuff but
also wanting to be there for work
because i also feel the same way with
streaming where i'm like i'm not there
enough i'm not participating in the
ecosystem enough you know so it's a
struggle do you ever have that problem
all the time right i mean recently i've
been
i've been trying to fix that by instead
reaching out to people that i haven't
talked to because that's yeah that's my
work around it's like yeah because like
people have if i get to the point where
people stop inviting me because i get
too busy yeah give your brain
i make
now i'm like all i want to do is work
but i'll schedule something in in like
two weeks because i'm like i'm it's not
right now it's not right now it's not
working yeah and it comes around i'm
like [ __ ] i want to work but i'm like
i'm glad i scheduled that because now i
can actually force myself to go and have
a good time and not think about doing
work i feel like moving has helped you
as well because i remember before you'd
never invite people to your place at all
because because it's a master's it was a
mess well pewdiepie roasted me
yeah but now you're in a more central
place so it's easier to just like invite
people and sort out your own because you
know when when i lived like an hour away
at like a minimum of an hour journey
right
an hour is a long time to lose in a day
when i try and make every goddamn hour
account yeah so when two hours because
they're back right you know now it's a
lot quicker for me which is great for
most places um but yeah i would spend so
much time traveling and i can't i'm not
the kind of person who can work on a
train i don't know about you oh no you
can't definitely definitely not tokyo
trains yeah you know if i'm standing
there's absolutely no way i can do any
work yeah sometimes i can't i figured
out a way dude do you get this thing
those houses how what worked you do on a
train well i can answer emails i can
work on scripts because you can do it
okay [ __ ] off can you work on scripts on
the train
do you ever okay do you ever have right
i don't know if this is another thing or
this is just a me thing right i have
these things right it's an email but
it's an email that i need to sit down
and look at yeah it's a focus email yeah
yeah i can't do it when i'm standing i
gotta sit down and be like
okay
hundred percent yeah i don't have that i
don't i'm envious i i have that like i
can't answer important emails on my
phone i need to like sit down on a
laptop or a computer it feels so much
nicer yeah yeah you don't have the big
screen so i can think about my words on
a bigger resolution i don't know why
that matters do you activate different
neurons when you sit down like i thought
he backed me up here do you do this i
agree actually entirely especially when
it comes to music um though sometimes
i'll be like i'll be like on a plane on
a train i get my phone out i'm like i'm
ready to work and i'm like nope time for
a nap and i just put my phone away
people who will complains are like just
like what happened in their childhood
complaints what happened in your
childhood i can work on playing [ __ ]
up it's working on a plane is different
than working on a train okay
with a train
you're like doing this in the [ __ ]
cabin there's people next to you like
they bring the food over you're like oh
[ __ ]
cause because because on a plane you are
you're on my phone
no no no no you don't work on your phone
joey
you need a [ __ ] laptop or at least a
tablet a phone
you can't pretty rough
no i mean what happens is i think i'm
going to so three levels of psychopaths
i put it on the table and i'm ready to
work and then suddenly um someone comes
with a glass of chardonnay they're like
here you go i'm like all right well i
gotta find a freaking place for this and
i turn on the thing and i'm looking at
the map and i'm like i wonder what
movies they have yeah yeah suddenly i'm
looking at the movies holy [ __ ] they
have this one i want to see if
if i was in like first class of business
i had the whole [ __ ] thing set up
yeah okay maybe we can talk about
working what i'm an economy i don't i'm
just depressed i don't want to think
about work i want to watch whatever
jason statham
no i'm depressed because you know
there's no good movies on it's always
it's always [ __ ] movies which i hate
yeah it's it's playing movies so if i'm
going to be in a bad mood i might as
well be in a bad mood and do some work
you know that's that's that's mine
that's exactly like that's why like i
hate like watching movies on a plane
because for one they're all movies i
don't want to watch i'm like well what
is there to do i'm not just going to
like [ __ ] blankly stare out the
window yeah yeah exactly take a nap i
don't know yeah i just like oh okay when
i say one i can't sleep yeah when i say
i work on a plane i'm not working yeah
the whole [ __ ] trip yeah jerry's like
making calls sell my stuff god damn it i
haven't seen my kids in three days
no okay if i'm like flying from tokyo to
l.a right it's like what 10 11 hour
flight
i'm probably working max like three or
four hours yeah same thing the rest of
the time the rest of the time i'm like
reading a book or like taking a nap or
watching a movie god forbid yeah like
doing something else basically like i'm
not that much of a [ __ ] machine where
i'm like 11 hours on this flight all
right 11 full hours of work like
mudan is the only guy yeah
oh you need a video editor let me whip
out my phone real quick
oh my god he's done that yeah right he's
done that before
he's he's used the
remote control on his phone to edit
on his pc yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying this guy's
plugged into the matrix this is it this
is when you reach your final form yeah
this is
this is the final evolution of like
humans you know
but like how do you script on your phone
like especially if you're standing up
right in a crowded train it's just it's
impossible for me to get the right
mindset let alone i can't get like a
single thought together so if i'm in
like a crowded train i'm not writing
script i'm like doing like the research
for the script because it's easy enough
to just you know because you're already
on your phone on a crowded train right
like looking at twitter or whatever so
what's the difference between looking at
twitter and looking at like a web page
or you know or like an anime user
philip defranco i'm just like yeah or
like a youtube video right like it's
it's the same motion but like i'm not
there [ __ ] typing it out on a crowded
train obviously not like if i if i'm
sitting down on the train sure i can
[ __ ] whip it out and start typing
some [ __ ] in but i don't know i i wish i
had that power man i mean if you did
that you'd probably be able to upload
every week
maybe that's what's missing
wishes
oh shut
i mean do you find like you have to be
in a certain environment when you write
your music or is it just like whenever
inspiration hits that's a good question
to be completely honest i can't force it
i just can't sometimes i'm in the mood
to write this song sometimes i'm not and
if i force it then the lyrics are going
to turn out real bad so
um i just have to be really mindful of
when i'm feeling that inspiration though
it does happen to
it does get a bit stronger as the
deadline creeps up it's not
procrastination i promise it's just
that's what they all say
i feel that making music is a completely
different part of your brain that is
doesn't overlap with any other type of
activity definitely yeah like i couldn't
write music on a plane or anywhere
that's not my room or and even when i'm
in my room i need to be a as you as
kelly said i need to be in like a
specific mood that's me in scripting
like i need to be in like a specific i
can do like admin stuff on my phone and
[ __ ] like that but like scripting's like
sacred that's probably why your
scripting is way better than mine it
sounds like you have that with
everything though gone sounds like
you've to be in the mood to [ __ ] as well
i mean there's nothing wrong with being
in the mood to [ __ ]
this man everything needs to be in a
monk like zen mode to get everything
done
we're like god can you order some food
now it's not the time i need to be in
the right minds
i just i just get distracted too easily
you do you do you do you
a genius takes a while yeah
if you stop like if you actually open
the [ __ ] app yeah
that's what i need like the certain apps
that i'm comfortable with i want to stay
on those apps don't don't give me
anything new tick-tock scares me okay
yes i'm a boomer okay
say it say it no no no no okay god
you're going to age way better than me
i'm just jealous
he has the upper hand now how does it
feel looking at chris and being like i'm
going to be that in five years
that's brutal too
oh my god